so he will uh be in the uh in his office
in downing street as he has been on a
on a zoom call but yes the government i
think are looking
at ways uh to also uh reduce the length
of time by which we all have to
quarantine if you were asked to
self-isolate
either through someone phoning you or on
the app currently at 14 days
but the hope is that they can reduce
that number and why ministers looking at
it well partly because of compliance
it's just simply too long for many
people to think that's sustainable
either in terms of loneliness or indeed
in terms of their economic need
to get out and work so let's look for
that too
the other good news of course has been
the oxford vaccine
today so while we're going to be going
again into a tiered system
while we're still going to have to live
with kovid restrictions for a few months
there is hope now
uh that we've now got three uh vaccines
on stream that could be going
to be distributed even before christmas
so
there is some real cause for optimism
finally after what's been a really
difficult year
and i suppose the way that the prime
minister portrays the message today is
important given that vaccine news given
the optimism that the light at the end
of the tunnel
given the relaxation potentially around
christmas but
to make sure that people don't relax too
much in the meantime beth
yes that's right and and also um if you
if you think about it um the government
uh when they said they were going to end
the restrictions in december the second
it was predicated wasn't it on the r
number being below one when you look
across the country
the r number is not below one it's still
at one point one to one
point two but the political imperative
for the prime minister
uh he knows it because he's got his back
benches threatening to cause him
huge problems and also the business
effect of
all of those retailers and hospitality
companies beauty salons clothing
outlets all trying to do business in the
run-up
to christmas so i think broadly what
we're going to see
from this tiering system is as much
effort to try and reopen the economy
but i think in terms of socializing and
our social interactions
that will be where the government will
be tough they want us to spend our money
but they don't want us to be in too much
contact
and maybe people will accept that
because they know
that come just before christmas will at
least
have a little bit of relaxation so we
can spend time with our loved ones
that does however mean more hardship
than for the hospitality
sector beth potentially
yes sarah i mean uh in the past tearing
system
in tier three all pubs and restaurants
were forced
uh to close unless they were serving
food questions about whether they
toughen up those regulations
we can still have takeouts that's what
we've all been doing hasn't it in not
national lockdown
but will they make it tougher for the
hospitality
industry i imagine that what people will
be looking for
in business is just the opportunity to
begin
trading again but as i said in terms of
hospitality and socializing
we still expect to see quite strict
limits on interaction
with people because of course it's
social interaction that spreads the
covid virus
and as for christmas beth news about
what it might look like
leaked yesterday but is the prime
minister yet in a position to make an
announcement
on that well he's not sarah because what
he is trying to do is get a genuine
four nation approach because obviously
lots of us
travel to different nations uh in the uk
around the united kingdom to see
families so what the government's doing
is there was a cabinet meeting yesterday
as i understand it a blueprint has been
drawn up
but we don't expect an announcement
until the prime minister has got that
signed off with all the devolved
administrations so that involves
discussions and negotiations uh with all
the devolved
administrations and governments so the
plan
is not signed off but as i understand it
uh the hope is that we can have a few
days
of relaxed rules uh maybe five days
and that perhaps three households uh
could mix
together so you could genuinely have a
family christmas
uh it might not be you know everyone and
the distant cousins but certainly
extended families
uh should be able to meet but as i said
that's got to be signed off
uh by all of the devolved
administrations that announcement could
come
as early as tomorrow but it depends how
those talks go
just to explain to viewers what is
happening at the moment we were
expecting the prime minister's statement
at half past three but you can see
the education secretary gavin williamson
on his feet continuing to take questions
then they will
clear the house for a few minutes and
then we will hear
from the prime minister and let's return
to the issue of christmas because that
is at the forefront of many people's
minds beth in order to have this
relaxation of the rules and families
able to to get together
over christmas what is the payoff for
that we heard from public health england
last week didn't we about what might
need to be done if we do have that
relaxation
yes sarah well last week one of um
the members of the public health england
team
uh said that for every one day that the
rules
are relaxed that's five days of title
restrictions so if you do the math
uh five days of freedom at christmas
around the christmas period
means title restrictions for 25 days
through to the end of december and into
january but i think that the expectation
certainly is that these tiers are not
just
up to the run-up for christmas the nhs
obviously uh has the flu uh
annual flu issue over christmas
and the winter where there is a real
squeeze and pinch
in terms of resource now overlay that uh
with covid so certainly this tier in
system and restrictions
i think we should prepare uh that these
could run through to next spring i mean
chris whittie professor chris whittie um
the chief medical officer
the prime minister himself has made it
very clear
that we are going to be living uh with
covid and the pressures on the nhs in
the already pressurized winter season
through to next spring so yes there will
be some relaxation around christmas
yes we will be going back to a tiered
system rather than this english national
lockdown before christmas but coming out
on the other side
it won't be life back to normal we will
still be living in a tier system i
imagine what the government will do is
what they've done
uh with the national lockdown now which
is that they will keep these measures
under review it might be that different
regions move between different tiers
depending on what the virus is doing in
local areas how much has it been
transmitted i imagine that they'll look
at hospital numbers
the r number uh to see uh how they can
flex those tears but this will very much
be done i would imagine in lockstep with
the nhs because the whole reason for
going into that national lockdown
was because of the concern around
critical care beds
and was the nhs going to run out of
capacity or capacity
be under threat so that's why the
government introduced this circuit
breaker you'll remember
there was a recommendation from sage to
bring it in much earlier than they did
but they decided to move
in november we're going to come out of
this national
lock down this english national lockdown
on december the second
but your life may not be that much
different in terms of how much you can
move around and see your friends
and in terms of of who goes where with
the tier
system beth we're not expecting that
today that
later on in the week why is that yeah
that's right sir because
what the government's going to do is
going to lay out the framework today
and then in terms of the tiering system
they want to look at the data
on wednesday night and then once they've
looked at the latest data they then
decide
which parts of the country go into which
tiers but i have to tell you
that my expectation is that perhaps
more of the country will be in higher
tiers
than we were previously you remember
half of
england was in tier one before we went
into the national lockdown but such was
the concern
about the spread of the virus that the
government felt
they needed national measures a huge
u-turn
on the policy that they were pursuing
from september onwards and the policy
that they hoped would get them
through christmas so we'll know on
thursday which
tier we're all going to be living in but
but now we're going to have an
opportunity to hear from the prime
minister
he'll lay out exactly what the new rules
are he'll explain hopefully how
they're changing from before and i would
expect the government to publish quite a
meaty
document later today so we can all go
through it
and work out what the rules are which
rules apply to you
you're going to have to wait until
thursday to find out
um we are expecting the prime minister
at any moment
now but it is going to be a busy week in
terms of statements isn't it beth
because we've got the prime minister
now we're hearing from him later in
downing street we're waiting
potentially tomorrow for the
announcement on what christmas
may look like thursday for who goes into
what tier we're also going to be hearing
a significant statement from the
chancellor
uh this week setting out his spending
review
yes so that it really is a very busy
week in which the government's tackling
both its winter covered plan
and as you said the spending review from
the chancellor smack bang
in the middle of this while he's going
to lay out uh
spending commitments to departments only
a one-year plan normally this would be a
three-year view
but the government feeling at the moment
that the public finances are in such
flux
because of kovid 19 that they're not
able
to do that but it really will lay bear
both the cost of covid
and also this will give us the first
takeaway snapshot
of what it's done to the public finances
what does the debt
figure look like what does the borrowing
figure look like
what does the joblessness total uh look
like
what is the state of the public finances
and i think it's going to be
quite a brutal statement on wednesday
when the cost
the level of borrowing and the cost to
the economy that kovid has had
that really will be felt and here is the
prime minister now
thank you very much and with your
permission to make a statement on the
government's
kobe winter plan for the first time
since this wretched virus took hold
we can see a root out of the pandemic
the breakthroughs in treatment in
testing vaccines
mean that the scientific cavalry is now
in psych
and we know in our hearts the next year
we will succeed
by the spring these advances should
reduce the need for the
restrictions we've endured in 2020 and
make the whole
concept of a copied lockdown redundant
when that moment comes it will have been
made possible
by the sacrifices of millions of people
across the uk
i'm acutely conscious that no other
peacetime prime minister
has asked so much of the british people
and just as our country has risen to
every previous trial
so it has responded this time and i
am deeply grateful but the hard truth mr
speaker is that we're not there
yet first we must get through winter
without the virus spreading out of
control and squandering
our hard-won gains at exactly the time
when the burden on the nhs is always
greatest
our winter plan is designed to carry us
safely
to spring in recent weeks families and
businesses in england have
once again steadfastly observed
nationwide restrictions and they've
managed to slow the growth
of new cases and ease the worst
pressures
on our nhs i can therefore confirm
the national restrictions in england
will end
on the 2nd of december and they will not
be renewed from next wednesday
people will be able to leave their home
for any purpose
and meet others in outdoor public spaces
subject to the rule of six
collective worship weddings and outdoor
sports can resume
and shops personal care gyms and the
wider leisure sector
can reopen but without sensible
precautions
we would risk the virus escalating into
a winter
or new year surge the incidence of the
disease is alas
still widespread in many areas so
we're not going to replace national
measures with a free-for-all
the status quo anti-covered we're going
to
go back instead to a regional
tiered approach applying the toughest
measures where covid is most prevalent
and while the previous local tiers did
cut the number
and cut the r number they were not quite
enough
to reduce it below one so the
scientific advice i'm afraid
is that as we come out our tears need to
be made
tougher in particular in tier one
people should work from home wherever
possible in tier two
alcohol may only be served in
hospitality settings
as part of a substantial meal in tier
three
indoor entertainment hotels and other
accommodation
will have to close along with all forms
of hospitality
except for delivery and takeaways and
i'm very sorry obviously for the
unavoidable hardship that this will
cause for
business owners who've already endured
so much disruption
this year mr speaker
unlike the previous arrangements tears
will now be
a uniform set of rules
we've also and that's to say we won't
have negotiations on
additional measures with each uh region
it's a uniform set of rules and
uh we've learned uh from experience uh
that there are some things we can do
differently so
from the 10 pm closing time hospitality
uh we're going to change that so that it
is last orders
at 10 with closing at 11.
in tiers one and two spectator sports
and business events will be free to
resume
inside and outside with capacity limits
and social distancing providing more
consistency
with indoor performances in theaters and
concert halls
will also strengthen the enforcement
ability of local authorities including
especially trained officers and new
powers to close down premises that pose
a risk
to public health last later this week i
should say
uh we will announce which areas will
fall
into which tier i hope on thursday
based on analysis of cases in all
age groups especially the over 60s
also looking at the rate by which cases
are rising or falling
the percentage of those tested in a
local population
who have coveted and the current and
projected pressures
on the nhs i'm sorry to say we expect
that more regions will
fall at least temporally into higher
levels than before but by using these
tougher tiers
and by using rapid turnaround tests
on an ever greater scale to drive
r below one and keep it there it should
be possible
for areas to move down the tiering scale
to lower levels of restrictions
by maintaining the pressure on the virus
we can also
enable people to see more of their
family and friends
over christmas mr speaker
i can't say that christmas will be
normal
this year but in a period of adversity
time spent with loved ones
is even more precious for people of all
faiths
and none we all want some kind of
christmas we need it we certainly feel
we deserve it but what we don't want
is to throw caution to the winds and
allow the virus
to flare up again forcing us all back
into
lockdown in january so
to allow families to come together while
minimizing the risk we're working with
the devolved administrations on a
special time limited
christmas dispensation embracing the
whole of the united kingdom
and reflecting the ties of kinship
across
our islands but
this virus obviously is not going to
grant a christmas
truce it doesn't know it's christmas
mr speaker and families will need to
make
a careful judgment about the risk of
visiting
elderly relatives we'll be publishing
guidance for those who are clinically
extremely vulnerable
on how to manage the risks in each tier
as well
as over christmas as we work to suppress
the virus
with these local tears two
scientific breakthroughs will ultimately
make these restrictions obsolete
as soon as a vaccine is approved
we will dispense it as quickly as
possible
but given that this can't be done
immediately
we will simultaneously use
rapid turnaround testing the lateral
flow testing
that gives results within 30 minutes
to identify those without symptoms so
they can isolate
and avoid transmission we're beginning
to deploy
these tests in our nhs and in care homes
in england
so people will once again be able to hug
and hold hands with loved ones
instead of waving at them through a
window
by the end of the year this will allow
every care home
resident to have two visitors who can be
tested
twice a week care workers
looking after people in their own homes
will be offered weekly tests
from today and from next month
weekly tests will also be available to
staff in prisons
food manufacturing and those delivering
and
administering covered vaccines we're
also
using testing as the house knows to help
schools and universities
stay open and testing will enable
students
to know they can go home safely for
christmas
and indeed back from home to university
but there is another way of using these
rapid tests
that is to follow the example of
liverpool
where in the last two and a half weeks
over two hundred thousand people
have taken part in a community test
community testing
contributing to a very substantial fall
in infections so together with nhs test
and trace and our fantastic
armed forces we will now launch a major
community
testing program offering all local
authorities in tier three areas in
england
a six-week surge of testing
the system is untried and there are
of course many unknowns but if it works
we should be able to offer those
who test negative the prospect of fewer
restrictions
for example meeting up in certain places
with others
who have also tested negative
and those towns and regions which engage
in community testing will have a much
greater chance
of easing the rules the tiering that
they currently
endure mr speaker
we will also use daily testing to ease
another restriction that has impinged
on many lives we will seek to end
automatic isolation
for close contacts of those found
positive
beginning in liverpool later this week
contacts who are tested
every day for a week will only need to
isolate
if they themselves test positive
if successful this approach will be
extended across the health system
uh the health system next month and to
the whole of england
from january and of course we're working
with the devolved administrations to
ensure
that wales scotland northern ireland
also benefit as they should and will
from these advances
in rapid testing
but clearly the most hopeful advance of
all
is how vaccines are now edging ever
closer
to liberating us from the virus
demonstrating emphatically that this is
not a pandemic without end
we can take great heart from today's
news
which has the makings of a wonderful
british
scientific achievement the vaccine
developed with
astonishing speed by oxford university
in astrazeneca is now one of three
capable of delivering a period
of immunity we don't yet know
when any will be ready and licensed
but we have ordered 100 million doses
of the oxford vaccine and over 350
million
in total more than enough for everyone
in the uk the crown dependencies
and the overseas territories and
the nhs is preparing a nationwide
immunization program
ready next month the like of which we've
never witnessed
mr speaker 2020 has been
in many ways a tragic year when so many
have lost loved ones and faced
financial ruin and this will be still a
hard winter christmas cannot be
normal and there's a long road to spring
but we have turned a corner and the
escape route
is in sight we must hold out
against the virus until testing and
vaccines come to our rescue and reduce
the need for restrictions and everyone
can help speed up the arrival
of that moment by continuing to follow
the rules
getting tested and self-isolating when
instructed remembering
hands face space and pulling together
for one final push
to the spring when we have every reason
to hope and believe that the
achievements of our scientists will
finally lift the shadow of this virus
and mr speaker
i commend this statement to the house
can i just say the prime minister it's a
big statement he ran three minutes over
so can i say to the opposition an extra
two minutes into the smp an extra minute
i know called the leader of the
opposition writer and mulkistama
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement
and for his telephone call earlier today
when he set out a summary of the
proposal let me start with the good news
the tremendous progress on vaccines last
week the shadow chancellor and i went to
the oxford vaccine group
at oxford university it was inspiring it
is
remarkable to see the work that they are
doing and our thanks and i think
of the whole nation go to all those
who've taken part in the vaccine trials
and res and research and we wish them
god speed
i also want to make an open offer to the
prime minister
labour will provide any support we can
in the national effort to deliver the
vaccine safely
across the country that's an open offer
can i also welcome the fact that the
prime minister is seeking a four nation
approach
on the arrangements over the christmas
period we'll obviously await details
on this and the evidence that supports
the steps being taken but the four
nation approach
is the right approach now for the more
difficult bit
the vaccine is the light at the end of
the tunnel
the question today is how do we get
there and protect lives and livelihoods
along the way the prime minister
proposes a return to the three-tier
system
that's risky because the previous
three-tier system didn't work
tier one areas drifted to tier two
almost all tier two areas ended up in
tier three
and those in tier three couldn't see a
way out and we ended up in national
lockdown
that was the sad reality of the tiered
system before and nobody wants a repeat
of that now i accept that the new tears
are different to the old tears
but many of the questions are the same
they're not trick questions
and i do acknowledge that none of this
is easy but if the prime minister is
going to carry parliament and the
country on this
they do need answering firstly on the
tier system
the prime minister touched on this but
which local errors will be in each tier
this is the red hot question this is the
question everybody is going to be asking
over their kitchen table tonight i had a
round table
with business leaders this morning and
it's the first question they
asked me the prime minister says it will
be decided later this week
possibly thursday i just can't emphasize
how important it is that these decisions
are taken
very quickly and very clearly so
everybody can plan
that's obviously particularly important
for the millions
who are in restrictions before the
national lockdown because the message to
them today seems to be
you will almost be certainly be back
where you were
before the national lockdown probably in
even stricter restrictions and people
need to know that
so they can plan for that and i really
emphasize how important
that is for the prime minister secondly
um and the prime minister said he wanted
uniform rules will the tears simply be
imposed
region by region come what may from the
3rd of december
or will there be an element of local
consultation
and negotiation i understand the uniform
rules
but simply to impose it runs the risk of
not getting buy-in from local leaders
and local communities which is
incredibly important to people
uh complying with the rules
third how long does the prime minister
anticipate each local area will it will
remain in each tier
for those that are going to come out of
lockdown and almost certainly go back to
more restrictions than they left
that's going to be a very very pressing
question
for them and then fourth will there be a
new economic package to accompany these
new
tiers this huge concern
among many businesses about the
viability in tier three particularly
strengthened tier three so what new
support can they
uh expect and can i touch again on those
who are self-employed who are outside of
the self-employed
scheme the so-called excluded because
they will be hearing a message about the
next three months
in relation to schemes they are not
currently in and that needs
urgently to be addressed could i then
turn to the public health impact of this
approach
because one of the major reasons that we
ended up in a national lockdown
was because in the words of the
government's own scientific advisers
sage
test trace and isolate was only having a
marginal impact on transmission it's one
of the reasons
they suggested a national lock marginal
impact on transmission
now i know the prime minister will talk
about increased testing
mass testing that's welcome but it's
only part of the story
because the other two parts trace and
isolate
are not fit for purpose saged advised
and continues to advise that for tests
for trace and isolate to be effective
the percentage of contacts
traced needs to be about 80 percent
it's currently nowhere near that level
it's never been near that level
and the figures are not getting any
better the latest figures actually show
that
every week about 120 000 close contacts
that's people who should be
self-isolating and not being traced by
the system
the likelihood of getting the virus
under control when 120 000 people who
should be self-isolating
are moving around their communities is
very low
and then only a fraction of people able
to self-ice late
are doing so when asked to do so now we
said to the prime minister this needed
to be fixed
in the period of the national lockdown
and it hasn't been
it's barely mentioned in the prime
minister's statement today
and many people will be forgiven for
thinking that the prime minister's given
up
on trace and isolate and is about to
abandon that scheme altogether
to reach out for a different scheme the
mass testing and it's very important
that we understand
that if we're going into a tiered system
abandoning trace an isolate or not
getting traced like
tracing isolate where it is we are
running a major
risk mr speaker this isn't about
knocking those on the front line
or knocking those working on track and
trace it's about being grown up about
risk
if we're reintroducing a three-tier
system without having fixed trace and
isolate
that is a major risk and we all need to
acknowledge it
because it begs the million-dollar
question which is how
confident is the prime minister that the
he's proposing today
will keep the r rate below one
because if it doesn't the infections
will go
up they will go back out of control
and we could well be back in a national
lockdown that is the million-dollar
question mr speaker labor has backed the
prime minister on all the big decisions
the government's had to take to protect
public health
including the two national lockdowns
we've done so
because we want that to be a national
consensus on difficult issues
like this and because we'll always put
public health first
ideally i would like to be in a position
to do so again
but there are huge gaps in this plan
huge uncertainties
and huge risks we will await the detail
we want the prime minister to get this
right he's got a week to do so
can he start by answering these
straightforward questions
thank you mr speaker prime minister
yes mr speaker well i'd like to thank
the right honourable gentleman for
his his qualified welcome of these of
these measures uh
he says that uh they are risky it's not
quite clear whether he's
uh supporting them or not i think
they're the right thing for the
for the country i think they're the
right way of uh of getting the
the virus done he wants to go back into
another uh
we'll keep a national lockdown on i
don't think that's the right way forward
for this
uh country uh we want to get the economy
moving as far as we possibly can
uh keep schools open whilst uh whilst
depressing the virus he asked when we'll
make the announcement about uh who goes
into which tier
as i said to him earlier on and i said
in my uh
statement just now that will be
announced on thursday the reason for the
delay mr speaker is quite simply that we
need to
to see the data as it as it comes in and
of course
uh we will uh work with uh local
uh authority leaders about uh about
which
uh tiers that they need to to apply
we'll discuss it with
uh with them but in the end uh we have
to take some decisions and get on
and do it i think we saw uh from the
last experience
it was those uh local authorities uh
liverpool springs to mind
uh that went early that were very
collaborative
uh where they'd be most successful
actually in getting
uh the incidents down and some of the
things that we'll look at
in deciding uh which uh tier is
appropriate mr speaker
case detection rates in all groups uh
case detection rates in the over
60s the rate at which the cases are
rising or falling the positivity rate
uh overall and the pressures on the nhs
in the
in the region those are the things that
we will uh be looking at mr speaker as
we make our judgment and they
clearly uh in some ways the the tears
have been
uh being changed i mentioned the point
about curfews uh
uh there are there are extra the
possibilities for
uh indoor and outdoor sports
as i said in my uh in my statement uh at
an indoor and outdoor events as i said
in my statement
uh it is right uh that the the balance
of the
impact of these should continue uh to be
to be tough
and he once again
criticizes nhs test and trace
mr speaker people should bear in mind
that
this operation has helped indisputably
in identifying the areas that have the
greatest
prevalence of disease it's helped us to
drive down
uh that disease uh in in those areas
it's been an immense value they're now
testing uh they have capacity over 500
000 a day
they've tested nhs tests and traits has
done more than any other country
in europe and uh what
is so exciting about the new lateral
flow testing is that
when it comes to uh to isolate uh there
is the
uh the prospect of using uh lateral flow
tests
uh as i said uh to uh to to check
whether you're
or not you're actually uh infected or
infectious
uh and thereby uh to obviate the need
for the 14-day
quarantine so science is is really
beginning to write to
uh our rescue uh mr speaker and it's in
that context with the
the combination of uh of a tiering
system
and uh uh lateral flow test and
the gradual rollout uh in the weeks and
months ahead
of the vaccine that we're able to uh to
come out of the lockdown
uh next next when next wednesday and
make
the progress that uh that we've
described um i'm
grateful to uh the right oral general
for such
uh support as he felt able to offer at
this stage i'm
uh aware that uh his support is one of
those
things that uh kind of now you see it
now you don't
uh but never mind i'll take it uh while
it seems to be there
at least temporarily and uh look forward
to further conversations with him
uh within next week damien green
thank you mr speaker after the
tremendous news about testing
and the encouraging uh developments on
on vaccines
can i welcome the news that the blanket
national lockdown
is ending but in the spirit of a wise
constituent
who told me that if the government
imposes stupid rules
we'll all stop obeying the sensible
rules as well
can i ask my right honourable friend
that the new tears
be imposed at a local level districts
rather than counties or regions
because restrictions which people feel
are unfair to their particular community
will simply not be respected or obeyed
and this will itself have a damaging
effect on our long-term health
prime minister
my honorable my right honourable friend
and indeed the wisdom of his
constituent but i respectfully disagree
the people of this country
have been obeying the rules and they
and it's to an astonishing degree thanks
to the heroic effort of the people of
this country
uh in following the guidance and
following the
recent measures that we've got the r
down in the way that we have and we've
got the incidents down
in some of those areas where the disease
was was really taking off if you look at
the the graphs
uh in the northwest in in particular
it's now starting to track down
across the country and uh i have every
confidence in the
the wisdom of the british people to
follow uh sensible guidance and sensible
rules and on
on his point about local uh versus
regional uh
alas the the disease is no respecter of
borough
boundaries and we have to have uh some
some
some regions in which to constitute the
tiers uh that
are sensible and large enough right
let's head up to scotland with the smp
leader
ian blackford ian blackford
i would like to thank the prime minister
for advanced site of his statement and
for these
telephone calls elliott mr speaker
this morning people right across these
islands woke up to the
more encouraging news on the development
of vaccines to
fight this deadly virus it is right that
we pay tribute to the
remarkable efforts of thousands of
scientists across the world
who've worked at unprecedented speed to
produce these vaccines
all those scientists offer us hope that
there is a way out of this pandemic
based on the primacy of safety for our
society
far too often in the recent past
expertise in science
has been questioned or demeaned by
right-wing politicians so
let's now ensure that those same
politicians never forget
it is a commitment and dedication to
science that is now coming to our
society's rescue
mr speaker why else we all welcome that
hope on the horizon
they've remained for far too many of our
citizens who have not received
a single penny of support since the
beginning of
this pandemic three million freelancers
sole traders
and the recently self-employed all
remain excluded
from any of the economic support
established by this tory government
these include people right across our
community painters bricklayers musicians
artists entrepreneurs and plumbers
because of the choices made by this tony
government
they now face christmas with no help
and no support mr speaker
myself and my party have now been
raising this issue since march
eight months ago they excluded are not
asking for any special treatment
they're just looking for some of the
same fairness that others have seen
others have received support
they should also be getting it prime
minister
the chancellor spending review this
wednesday will take place exactly
one month from christmas day
so i have one very specific question
will the prime minister today guarantee
that a package of financial support
will finally be put in place for the
three million people
who have been exploded from any economic
support will there be
some pre-christmas cheer for the three
million
who have been excluded from help so far
prime minister
mr speaker and uh i think the right i
don't know who the right honourable
gentleman means in his attack on
uh those who uh those who don't
encourage the investment in science he
certainly can't mean this government
because we
uh put forward the biggest ever program
of investment in
uh in in r d and indeed are creating
uh a uh uh advanced uh
research projects uh facility that uh
will rival that of we hope of the united
states we're investing in pure science
and applied science
at a scale undrinked of by any previous
government i think to rising to 22
billion pounds
a year at the end of the spending review
period so i really don't know who he's
talking about but he's not
uh whichever right-wing foes uh the
right or
gentleman has in view uh it cannot be uh
this government
uh on his point about um uh supporting
the self-employed look
this has been very very difficult mr
speaker and we're we're doing whatever
we can
uh to help uh the self-employed and and
the the excluded
uh 13.5 billion has gone so far i think
more now to support
uh the self-employed those particularly
in the artistic
cultural sectors are beneficiaries of
the uh of the 1.57 billion pound
investment in in the arts and culture
but the best thing for everybody uh
is there are many things that apply
generally such as the cut on
uh on on vat and the uh the the bounce
back loans of all kinds that are
available to
uh in the grants that are available to
uh to everybody but the best thing for
uh everybody in all sectors is just to
get the economy uh
moving again uh to uh to get the virus
down and and to move forward and that's
the objective
of this winter plan mark thank you very
much
um mr speaker first of all uh prime
minister can i thank you for agreeing to
meet
uh myself and my honourable friend the
memphis wickham
on behalf of the 70 colleagues who wrote
to you at the weekend
we look forward to discussing this
matter in more detail later
um i think many will hold their um
judgment on this until we know which
areas go into which tiers i think if you
go into tier three
you'll struggle to spot much of a
difference from the lockdown
but can i ask the prime minister to set
out for each of the
restrictions which have such an impact
on people and businesses
the impact he's expecting it to have on
dealing with covid
but also the non-covered health impact
and
importantly the impact on people's
livelihoods so that we know
each measure is going to save more lives
than it costs
prime minister yes indeed mr speaker
we'll be very happy and i'm
i'm delighted to meet my rather humble
friend and uh the the the honourable
member for wickham uh who've written uh
an excellent letter to me many of the
points i hope he agrees in that letter
were answered in my uh statement about
uh about sport for curfew non-essential
uh retail gyms
have you pressed the button prime
minister
prime minister i think we're just going
to have to stop for a moment so we can
have it checked
we're just checking the sound prime
minister we've lost your answer
have you pressed the button by mistake
muted
she answers them
it's not our empire ministry it could
well be yours
i wonder if mr hancock would like to
take over with the answer
it's one of you gonna do it or not so
he's looking at each other sorry
we're gonna suspend for three minutes
then okay
well the prime minister is having
technical trouble and so
that statement and the questions before
the house being suspended for three
minutes as you just heard there
from the speakers lindsey hoyle while
they try to resolve
those uh problems but the prime minister
has set out
his covid winter plan what happens
when lockdown ends as the prime minister
has confirmed it will
on the 2nd of december let's bring in
our political editor beth rigby who was
listening
in so the prime minister set out the new
tier system a tougher
tier system uh that will come into
effect
after lockdown ends on the 2nd of
december
beth and just explain to us what it will
mean
well sarah there's so much detail isn't
there to go through but in the big
picture
i think the message here is that uh the
national
english lockdown will not be resumed
after december the second the prime
minister very clear about that we will
move
into a tier system but that will last
until the spring it's going to be a long
road ahead uh some glimmers on the
horizon of course in terms of
not just the vaccines but also testing
the prime minister talking about the
hope of maybe having
more effective testing to try and
release people
from isolation more quickly but i think
the big picture there the big message to
all of ours
is that this is going to be a long road
ahead
before we start living more normally
again and in terms of the actual
tiering system where you heard mark
harper who's
chair of the covered recovery group
of mps interesting the prime minister
said they're saying that he'd met with
those back bench
leaders of that group the unhappiness
plain to see
he's saying there mr harper uh that tier
three doesn't seem that different does
it
uh to the english national lockdown and
the big change in the tiering system is
that in terms of hospitality
if you are in tier three all the pubs
and restaurants remain
closed you can go for take out but you
cannot go and sit
uh in a bar with your family and have a
meal
uh indeed that that that kind of
freedom is now brought down to tier two
where you're allowed to go out and sit
with your family and have a meal
but no alcohol unless you're having a
proper substantial dinner
so the government there really
tightening
up the tears and there was another sting
in the tail wasn't there when the prime
minister said i'm afraid to tell you
that as we toughen up the tears also
more
of the country will be in the higher
tiers so it is going to be quite
restrictive
beth i'm going to interrupt you matt
hancock the health secretary is uh
standing in and continuing uh to answer
those questions while they reestablish
communications with the prime minister
it is necessary to be able to get the r
down under the tiered system to
avoid a further national lockdown
if the cases still go up and as we've
set out we have seen some areas of the
country uh
see the case rates come down and now
thankfully
nationally we're seeing the case rates
come down to his final point about
the other health and economic impacts we
of course recognize the economic impacts
or the other health impacts i would
simply reiterate what i've said many
times before
which is that the health impacts of not
looking down
and of the spread of the coronavirus
going too broad
on other health conditions other than
coronavirus are
also bad and the best way to protect the
health of the nation both from
coronavirus and from all other
conditions
is to keep the virus under control david
thank you mr speaker i think it makes
the case for investing in broadband um
can i ask the secretary of state though
very seriously from the lack of tests
and ppe
the claims about a protective ring
around care homes
while people died in horrifying numbers
the government's abject failure to
protect
care home residents and care staff has
been one of the biggest tragedies of
this pandemic
so will sacrifice state guarantee today
that no care home in england will be
required
or pressurized to meet anyone from an
nhs hospital
who has tested positive for covet
well mr speaker we have over the summer
put in place a new regime
for ensuring that people who have tested
positive
but need to go to a care home can
get the support that they need in a way
that protects them
and also protects other residents
and that means that nobody leaves
hospital
without a test and those who do need to
leave hospital with the positive test
must be isolated in a cqc approved
isolation facility
and we do of course need to support
people who've tested positive and
hospital is often not the best place for
them but we need to do that in a way
that protects all other residents as
well
and at the same time i'm delighted that
we're able to announce today the
expansion
of the availability of testing for care
homes for
domiciliary care workers as well and
also for care home visiting which i know
is
is hugely welcomed thank you mr speaker
we've seen huge efforts across
stoke-on-trent to get
covered rates down and the city council
have done an excellent job
at rolling out testing rates are now
falling locally so will my autonomous
friend do everything possible to ensure
support continues to be given to local
health
and council services so we do not exit
lockdown
at the highest tier well i pay tribute
to everybody in stoke the council
at the royal stoke hospital and the
wider nhs
and the three colleagues in this house
who represent
uh stoke including my honorable friend
who have worked so hard together to get
the high quality public health messaging
out we can see the cases coming down in
stoke
and as the prime minister set out on
thursday
we'll take decisions we'll announce
decisions taking into account the very
latest data
on which areas fall into which tiers
thank you mr speaker while millions will
welcome
the fact that they will now be able to
shop
worship and associate with friends and
family over christmas
does the minister not realize how
alarming
this statement is today rather than
being grateful
for an announcement which allows us to
exercise some basic
freedoms should we not be alarmed
that the dependence to do the things
which
normally people would expect in a
democracy now
rest in the hands of a minister and the
state
and will and will he accept that this
today's statement will still deny
people the right to earn a living will
drive millions into poverty
and will still instill fear and that
should indicate that this policy is a
wrong track
um mr speaker the first duty of any
government is to
keep the citizens of the country that we
serve safe
and that is the reason that we take the
actions that we do
so buddley um i hope the secretary of
state won't think me too eccentric
uh if i say that on a winter's morning
uh i like to start my day by swimming
the serpentine and then going to
mass and of course he's now abolished
both those things the last four weeks
and more important
abolish them for hundreds of thousands
of people so my question to him is this
that under any tier or indeed under any
future lockdown
we will never return to the abolition
of healthy outdoor sports or going to
serve religious services there's never
been a shred of evidence that they cause
any problem by the way this is the first
time in 800 years of people have been
prevented from going to
church in this country since the
country's put under an interdict by a
medieval pope
so we do want reassurance on that and by
as we're
having this conversation could you give
us some some more reassurance about
christmas carols
we don't want it to be just a hurry
night or and we want we don't want to be
in a silent night either
mr um mr speaker
um i i very much hope that we won't have
another national lockdown
at all it's one of the reasons that
we've toughened up
the tier three is to ensure that if
areas
are in tier three we can get the virus
coming down as opposed to just flatten
at a high rate as we were seeing before
and that way i hope we can prevent the
whole
country from ever having to see the
sorts of restrictions
that we had to bring in in order to keep
people safe
it has to be said that news of the three
vaccinations brings us a much needed
dose
of hope as we face the winter months and
of course wales is especially vulnerable
to covid19 because of our older
population and our higher levels of
deprivation
will the secretary of state ensure that
wales receives a sufficient allocation
of vaccines
based on need and not perhaps a
population
it's absolutely vital that we do we
vaccinate
fairly across this country across the
whole of the uk
according to clinical need that is the
agreement that we have reached amongst
the four nations it's the principle
that i am determined to follow uh
for given that the uk vaccination
program
is obviously across the whole united
kingdom
and we've therefore on that basis agreed
a fair allocation of uh
a vaccine so that vaccination can occur
at the same speed in all parts of the
country according to clinical need
we're heading to your character or we
hope to be with julian sturdy julian
sturdy
thank you mr speaker given the big
sacrifices that york residents have made
to get the virus down locally does the
secretary of state accept how unfair it
will feel if the city is kept in high
tier restrictions
even when our copied rate is
considerably lower
than when we entered tier two and one of
the lowest in our regions
so does the secretary's state agree that
the new restrictions policy has to give
people hope
that self-discipline and resilience will
be rewarded
yes i do think that those values are
important and should be
rewarded and i hope that
the the areas of the country where the
case rate has really come down a long
way and is coming down fast
i do hope that we will see the
the fruits of that effort having said
that it is absolutely critical
that that areas that need to go into
at tier 3 do go into tier 3 in order
to to get the case rate down
and in order to protect the population
we'll take these judgments based on
public health advice uh and um
uh over the forth coming days the reason
that we haven't set those details out
today is that the more data we have
the better um and we want to give
businesses time to plan
to be able to reopen but at the same
time we do want to take into account the
very latest data and in york as in some
other parts of the country
the number of cases is coming down and
i'm i i welcome that and i want to see a
few more days data before we can take
those final decisions
let's head down to blind with caroline
lucas caroline lucas
thank you mr speaker if these tougher
tiers are to deliver sustained
reductions in transmission
then test trace isolate has to work
better
so will he learn the lessons from
countries where compliance with
self-isolation is much higher
pay people more when necessary offer
hotel accommodation if needed
fix the app so that people told to
self-isolate via the app
can now qualify for support and will the
government
stop repeating that they've given 13
billion for the self-employed
when three million of them have been
unfairly deemed to be ineligible
it's not good enough to say that it's
too difficult or wait till the economy
is moving again
please minister no ifs no buts no
excuses
when is he going to give those people
some hope
uh thank you very much uh mr speaker and
the
the the whole country knows that we are
going through
very difficult times but i hope that the
news
especially on vaccines that we've seen
over the past fortnight
taken together offers some hope
about the way we can get out of this she
mentions
uh the test and trace system i did as
did the right on the gentleman on the
front bench opposite i'm very glad to
say that not only is the testing
of regime and the opportunities that we
have to roll out testing expanding very
very rapidly and i pay tribute to the
team
but the contact racing is also
improving and i'm really pleased and pay
tribute to all those who've been working
to make that happen
let's head up to federation border with
dr neil hudson dr neil hudson
thank you mr speaker quite rightly we
are keeping young people in full-time
education at this time
the outdoor education sector provides an
amazing
parallel education for children and
there are many centres in cumbria and
across the uk
these centres are ready for covert
secure programs where pupils who are in
bubbles at school
can be safely accommodated will my right
honourable friend
work across government to look at
reopening these centers as soon as
possible
for residential visits so that whole
cohorts of young children
do not miss out on this vital and
life-affirming educational opportunity
so my honourable friend makes a very
powerful case
for a sector that is obviously prevalent
in his
uh uh beautiful constituency uh and i
look forward to working with him to see
what progress we can make
let's head to north down with stephen
ferry stephen furry
thank you mr speaker i i welcome the
progress it has been made
on a coordinated approach across the
four countries of the uk
around the christmas season given the
particular context of northern ireland
and indeed all the links across the rac
can the secretary of state ensure that
this planning also includes the irish
government
and in doing so can i suggest that the
most immediate priority is clarity
around travel arrangements
but some care does need to be taken in
relation to the precise guidance
around household mixing so today
well yes i'll absolutely take those
points on board
in the conversations that ministers are
having across
the uh devolved nations of the
uh of the united kingdom uh and the
point that he takes about the
the the enormous number of ties that we
have and family ties between the uk and
the republic of ireland
as well um as he knows the the common
travel area
uh is there between the uk and the
uh and the republic and so the and so
travel to the republic
um has uh has never been restricted uh
from the
uk side uh that's uh that's a point of
principle and a point of policy
uh and uh i know very important for the
people of northern ireland
thank you mr speaker it's uh welcome
news the ipswich hospital found out on
the 11th of november that
they will be receiving 5.2 million
pounds for a new molecular laboratory
this will allow hospitals to ramp up
rapid testing to almost 3 000 a day by
end of march we've also heard reports at
suffolk's first site
for delivering vaccinations will be
ready in two weeks time with the nhs
proposing gains for sports centre
in ipswich testing and vaccinations are
two crucial ways to beat the virus so
does my writing warfarin agree with me
that having ipswich at the forefront of
both of these key issues will be a real
boost interest residents
mr speaker we put millions of pounds
into ipswich
hospital and i know that my honourable
friend supports ipswich hospital
very strongly indeed and i'm glad that
across suffolk and across the whole of
the
country we're putting in place now the
uh the vaccination hubs that will be
there and ready
should the regulator sign off a new
vaccine i
i i don't want to uh intrude on the
um rigorous independence of the medical
uh regulator the mhra who will make a
decision on the safety of these vaccines
but
should it be approved then the nhs will
be ready
uh to begin the rollout and i set the
nhs
the challenge of ensuring that they can
roll out at the speed at which these
vaccines can be manufactured and
produced
let's go over to the mp for huddersfield
to bury sherman very sherman
thank you mr speaker and will the
secretary of state
impart to the prime minister my question
that will he can i beg him at this late
stage to change his
mind this is a national emergency
and if his policy announced today will
end up
with critical and perhaps tragic results
for my constituents and for our country
the fact of the matter is
that as soon as we go to a tier system
and i represent huddersfield in kirklees
which is a
classic average typical town in britain
we've worked better and harder than
anyone else
to get rates down and we have not been
successful
under a national plan we have started to
get there
we only got to keep ourselves going
under restriction
for a few more weeks and we will have
the antidotes
please change your mind minister change
your mind prime minister
we must stop deaths occurring that could
be avoided
well mr speaker the tiered
system that's been set out by the prime
minister today
is calibrated very carefully learning
all of the lessons
from the the the lockdowns that have
been in place and also the previous
tiered system
and evidence from around the world and
indeed from the devolved nations
to be calibrated to be able to bring
infections down
but do so in a way that also protects
the other things that
matter in life as much as possible it is
necessary that this
tier three in particular is tougher than
the previous
uh not least because of the experience
of uh huddersfield and kirklees and
other places that were in tier three for
quite a long time but saw a flattening
rather than a reduction
in their rates that's why we've brought
in a tougher tier three
but it is nevertheless uh does allow for
the opening of
uh of religious uh settings and of
non-essential retail which i know is so
important for many
um millions of people will be delighted
to hear that grass
roots sports will return from the 3rd of
december
can the secretary of state confirm that
will be the case in all three tiers and
also with regards to the tears
themselves
will consideration be given for
variances across big counties and
regions
for example the conditions in the thames
estuary can seem very different and
distant from those in the south kent
coast
yes i i'm delighted that outdoor sports
are able to
uh reopen uh i like the
culture secretary i have had uh
significant representations from
people who want to do exercise which of
course is good for your
health and i'm glad that we've been able
to do that uh when it comes to the
geography
of the uh of the application of the
tears
of course we've got to look at the areas
in which people live
and travel but at the same time as we
did previously
where where it is it's clear that you
can go
and there's a genuine difference
that isn't represented by administrative
boundaries
then we will look at that and make a
decision on that basis for instance in
the previous days we
we put we split even split a borough
into
in one example but nevertheless you do
also have to look
at where people live and travel
in order to get these decisions right
speaker
thousands of jobs have been lost in the
pub and hospitality sector and are going
to be lost
uh the prime minister beginning of this
crisis said that
government actions would follow the
science it's a recent meeting with the
national uh
health director he was clear that there
was no signs behind
the uh 10 o'clock soon to be 11 o'clock
curfew
and said it was a policy decision so if
there's no
science behind this decision
what uh are the reasons for it
well the the we have put enormous
amounts of support
to support the hospitality sector uh but
we do also understand the challenges
that the measures that were brought in
uh pose and the reason behind having to
have restrictions on hospitality is that
in order to protect
the ability of people to go to work and
in particular protect
education it is important nevertheless
to reduce the sadly the social contact
on which this
uh on which this virus thrives i mean it
is a
it is it is it is it is upsetting it's
frustrating
but it is true and it's clear
from the evidence that we've already had
that at later
in the evening and late at night social
distancing
declines and we know that when social
distance inclines so transmission
increases liam fox thank you mr speaker
can i ask the
prime minister through the medium of my
right honourable friend
uh what progress is being made in uh
getting
an integration between these lock down
measures and testing
at the country's airports shouldn't we
be following the example of other
successful countries
in helping to boost business travel help
the airline industry
help inwards and outward tourism and get
our
the workers at our airports back to
full-time employment what uh what
encouragement can you give those
in my own constituency at bristol
international airport
yes the uh this is really important and
it's another example of how the
increased capacity and testing that
we've built
can help improve lives i've been working
with the
my right on friend the transport
secretary and the airline industry
and the airports including the regional
airports which are
so important to try to get a a better
regime in place
and my right on friend won't have to
wait very long
to get an answer let's head up to
scotland with stewart c
mcdonald stuart c macdonald
thank you mr speaker the uplift to
universal credit was a welcome one but
people on legacy benefits the sick and
the disabled
have also faced additional costs and
hardship because of the pandemic and
many of those costs were incurred
simply to follow government advice on
shielding or protecting themselves
so how does he justify not applying the
same uplift
to those people and can we have this
injustice rectified
going forward
well many many people in those
circumstances also are receipted
in receipt of universal credit and we
have put in an increase
of a thousand pounds for those uh are in
receipt of universal credit
uh it is a very significant and generous
uh increase
alongside the furlough arrangements um a
a very very substantial package of
financial support
uh that the imf has described as one of
the most generous in the world
sure the 22 chagrin really thank you mr
speaker can i
return to the question that was asked by
our right honourable friend
from forrest of dean i think the
secretary of state said that he
recognizes
the damage that's done by these
restrictions will he go further and
publish the government's assessment of
what that
impact is both in economic terms and in
health terms
and can i also ask him will he ensure
that on thursday
when it becomes clear which regions are
going into which tier
the government publishes the exact
criteria which will be used to make that
judgment
yes we will uh publish the uh uh
the statistics that we look at to make
exactly the judgments that he
uh that he uh that my brother friend
refers to um it is not possible to put a
specific number on it though
and the reason that it's not possible is
because there are a number of criteria
and you wouldn't for instance want to
put
a an area into lockdown
or a higher tier more accurately because
it triggered
numerical criteria if there was a
specific reason
for instance there's been an outbreak of
barracks
in the last month very significant
outbreak it meant that that area looked
like it had a huge spike but it was
entirely
literally confined to barracks and
therefore an element of judgment
is important in making these decisions
but what we will do is publish the data
on which these decisions are taken
and raise the question also about the
economic impact
assessment and i'll raise that point
with my rightful friend the chancellor
we're still hoping to reconnect with the
prime minister at some point so in the
meantime we'll continue with jonathan
edwards
do you have mr speaker the news of the
successful development of three vaccines
is to be warmly welcomed because it
offers light to the end of the tunnel
but however
he will recognize that distribution will
be a huge logistical challenge
uh what guarantees can he give that the
welsh government will receive any
additional resources it requires to meet
the task at hand
uh whether uh the the the rollout the
the vaccines program is a uk
uh program uh and the costs of the
rollout of course incur
uh barnet consequentials and will
therefore be
uh available across the whole of the uk
uh we're working closely with the nhs in
wales
to make sure that this happens as
smoothly as possible
but it will be the most almighty huge
logistical effort for everybody involved
richard drax
mr speaker as my right-handed friend
knows i do not support lockdowns
tiered or otherwise but i welcome the
move to get these vaccines and it's very
very good news
as i understand it the government's the
main weapon the government has is test
and trace can i suggest
test and quick result is equally
important
when will the government be able to say
or can tell the house when the whole
country
can be tested and get a quick result so
when it's negative we can all get on
with our lives
i hope that the i hope that the system
so that people can test daily uh if
they've been in close contact as the
prime minister has
with somebody who's tested positive um
and
that be in place instead of having to
isolate as a contact
i hope that that will be in place in
january
uh as the prime minister set out we're
piloting it
uh from this week and then we'll roll it
out over
uh december and i hope it will be
available nationwide
from january okay thank you mr speaker
i'd like to ask the prime minister or
even the chancellor but can i ask the
secretary of state
with the infection rate still still high
across the northeast
it's looking like likely that the region
will come out
of this national lockdown in a worse
position than it went in
with the t when the tier restrictions
were last implemented
local leaders had to fight the
government for a fair amount of funding
for our region
can the secretary of state assure us
that this time the north will not be
left behind again
and in line with their leveling up
promise
and ensure that all businesses and
people receive the correct level
of financial support that they so
desperately need
well i'm glad to see that the number of
cases in the northeast
is falling and that's good news and
testament to people right across
the northeast yes there will be
financial support to the
to the councils that are in higher tier
areas alongside of course the huge
amount of financial support to
individuals through furlough and through
the increase to universal credit
and of course to businesses too headline
notes mr speaker
physical and mental well-being go hand
in hand and both are under attack from
this virus i welcome my right honourable
friends comment so far on outdoor sport
but at this time of year it's the
fitness studios the pilates studios the
dance studios
that are crucially important to keep
people active what reassurance can he
give the house
that even in areas where there is a
higher tier every effort will be made
to make sure that people can keep active
recognizing the enormous efforts the
industry has made to put in covert
secure measures
i i can give my right on a friend
exactly that assurance
and not least as in all tiers gyms will
be able to be open and i recognise the
enormous efforts that most gyms have
gone to to make sure that they're
covered secure
thank you mr speaker i talked to
hanslow's director of public health
this morning and she was welcoming the
opportunity
to have lateral flow testing rapid
testing
under her jurisdiction locally
and we both welcome the fact the
government has finally recognized
that local health and public health
professionals are essential
to the successful tackling of infection
uh
such as covid but councils and primary
health
uh trust cannot altogether roll out
rapid testing for vulnerable groups
and employ train uh and enforce
uh uh as just announced by the prime
minister
and roll out the vaccination program
without significant
additional resources now the army's been
helping in liverpool with the rapid
testing but will the government
adequately resource local authorities
and local health trusts
to deliver what's needed sure
she's absolutely right to praise local
public health officials and
local directors of public health have
done an amazing amount of work
throughout this crisis and we work
incredibly closely
with them right across the country what
i'd say on the
resource issue is absolutely it's very
important that
the further funding will come forward
for those areas in the higher
restrictions
not least because of the amount of work
that we all need to do together let's
head to lincoln with cole mccartney
carl mccartney
our ryan honourable friend the prime
minister said earlier 2020 has been a
difficult year
and unfortunately for freelancers and
directors limited companies in lincoln
across the uk
they've had a particular order this year
with many of them yet to receive
next to no financial report from the
government as yet whilst today's
announcements are welcome we are moving
in a positive direction many will still
have to wait several months before
small businesses can return to some form
of normality so i asked my right old
friend to
urge his very close friend the
chancellor to provide grant funding for
these individuals and businesses
local authorities can and will step in
to provide this funding on a case
by case basis and to finance this we can
seek the repayments of taxpayer funding
from the supermarkets who are quite
clearly misused taxpayer support that
they do not need
will my right honourable friend back the
blue collar conservative campaign and
write this wrong
i'd be very happy to look at it myself
and as you say and
take it up with my writing friend the
chancellor who as he knows will be at
the dispatch box on wednesday
let's head to barnsley with dan jarvis
don
jarvis thank you very much
mr speaker the government has committed
to level up the country and in
particular
the north of england but given the risk
that kovid will level us down
can i ask the secretary of state what
assurances he can give
that in wednesday's spending review the
chancellor will
reform the green book replace the local
growth fund with a shared prosperity
fund
and deliver the investment needed to
tackle regional inequalities
well yes the treasury has already
updated its uh
its green book and uh that is a
significant step and i know that the
chancellor
has been discussing uh this further
the leveling up agenda mr speaker is
absolutely critical
after this pandemic even more so than it
was before
it's the agenda on which everybody on
this side of the house was elected
with enormous enthusiasm about a year
ago
and we look forward to putting that in
place
with renewed vigor once this pandemic is
over
baldwin thank you mr speaker and given
how important
uh maintaining fitness levels is in
terms of being able to deal with
uh the illness could the secretary of
state confirm i heard him say
some welcome things about sport but will
people be able to go to indoor swimming
pools for example and will they be able
to play golf
um yes mr speaker um golf is back
and um outdoor sport
is um uh is uh absolutely
uh going to be available under all uh of
the
uh of the tiers and we'll be publishing
all of the details of this and what
works in each
tier imminently wendy chamberlain
thank you mr speaker now i welcome the
plans in place to test students enabling
them to travel home for christmas
and i commend the work of saint andrews
university in my constituency of north
east 5
who have stepped in to facilitate this
but a gap remains in the new year
we need to ensure students where
students must return to university can
do so safely
as well as giving reassurance to the
communities in which they're situated
i understand from the covert winter plan
that guidance will follow suit
but on behalf of the government can the
secretary advise me what engagement has
been had with devolved nations about the
return and testing of students in
january
including discussions around default
online teaching
yes this is it's a really important
subject to get right
the use of testing will allow it make it
easier
both for students safely to go home
and also then students safely to return
to university it's something that i've
discussed with my colleagues across
the four nations not least because so
many students go to university in
different parts of the united kingdom
and i hope we have a a good regime in
place for the return of students
in the same way that we have a good
regime in place
for students to be able to safely to go
home using those
new lateral flow tests that we now have
available thanks to the huge investment
and the work that we did over the summer
let's head up to burton with kate
griffiths great grips
thank you mr speaker so many businesses
and jobs in my constituency of burton
are based in pubs and in the brewing
industry they're not set up to provide
food and without further support
will struggle to make it through
december can i ask the prime minister
through my right honourable friend
to ensure that any support provided to
wet pubs
also includes the wider brewing industry
who will also be seeing a significant
decrease in trade
yes of course everybody knows that uh
burton is inescapably
linked to high quality beer and anybody
who's been to burton
uh knows knows that fact and and
i uh my heart goes out to the
hospitality industry
who've been hit so hard uh of course
there are there are the
schemes available uh nationally
including of course furlough
and the support for uh businesses
there has been more support for the
hospitality leisure
and accommodation businesses and there
will be cash grants
for businesses that are closed uh under
the new tiering system to try to support
people through what are inevitably very
difficult times
thank you mr speaker while i'm pleased
mr speaker that the prime minister and
the secretary of state have listened to
representation by myself and other
colleagues about the importance of
reopening
for instance gyms golf and collective
worship
i'm very disappointed that we heard
nothing from the prime minister about
helping those
small business people and more visitors
in my constituency who've got either
little or no help whatsoever
be financially excluded and should look
again at that right but my question mr
speaker is this
is that following a freedom information
request through my local ccg
i looked at cgp referrals from september
this year compared to september 2019 we
saw a huge drop
in the number of people referred for for
instance cardio gastric and trauma and
orthopedic
so while we've heard from the government
they're going to put extra financial
resources into the nhs can ask the
secretary of state
how how is it going to provide the extra
staff in terms of doctors nurses
and specialists so to get the waiting
list down
and to meet the surgeon referrals well
yes i'm glad to say that we're hiring
large numbers uh we're just going to
leave the commons now and bring you the
latest numbers
from the government on coronavirus cases
15
450 new covid19 cases
have been reported today that's compared
with 18
662. yesterday
206 deaths have been reported within 28
days
of a positive coronavirus test that is
down from 398
yesterday we should caution of course
there is the monday effect which we do
tend to see we have been listening to
the prime minister and then the health
secretary who stepped in when the prime
minister had some technical trouble
uh with his sound uh in the commons
setting out that national lockdown in
england will end
on december the 2nd but the pm said the
hard truth is
we're not there yet we will not be
replacing national measures
with a free for all we will be returning
to a regional
tiered approach applying the toughest
measures where covid is most prevalent
at that tier system under tier 1 it
means
people should work from home wherever
possible under tier
2 in hospitality alcohol will only be
served with
a substantial meal under tier
3 indoor entertainment hotels
hospitality etc will have to
close except for takeaways
and delivery nationwide
post december the second non-essential
shops hairdressers gyms and leisure
facilities will reopen across the whole
of england
collective worship weddings all outdoor
sports can resume
subject to social distancing the rule of
six will return
meaning people will no longer be limited
to seeing only one other person
in outdoor public spaces across
the uk and who goes into which tier we
will find out
on thursday lots more on this coming up
from mark austin next in the pm again at
7.